for all of the books I don't have time
for I use short form which condenses
thousands of non-fiction books down into
an excellent summary that I can read or
listen to all at once short form goes
chapter by chapter providing deeper
analysis than other summary platforms
for a more comprehensive understanding
of any topic try it free and get 25 off
using my link below
well I'm back everybody good to be back
and so much to discuss we'll start with
the situation in Russia a failed coup
attempt which Vladimir Putin has
survived but to what end and with what
long-term impact we just don't know but
let's go through what took place over
the weekend incredible uh the Wagner
group Wagner group everybody has their
own way of pronouncing it launched a
coup attempt by sending tanks and troops
towards the Russian capital of Moscow
hoping to overthrow Vladimir Putin and
put in some kind of puppet leader quite
frankly the mercenary group the Wagner
group is led by yevgeni pragosian uh
formerly a close associate of Vladimir
Putin's sanctioned by the U.S for his
role in interfering in the 2016 and 2020
elections and pregosian's alliance with
Putin uh Howard when he accused Putin
rather he accused the the Russian
defense minister of incompetence and
betrayal claiming that he had ordered
attacks on Wagner's troops in Ukraine
and elsewhere the timeline as far as we
understand it is that on Friday June
23rd pagosian threatened Rebellion
Saturday June 24th very early just hours
later one in the morning on Saturday
Vladimir Putin was briefed about the
armed Rebellion that was being
threatened by 7 30 a.m the Wagner group
claimed control over rostov military
facilities and the airport two hours
later the March towards Moscow began 10
a.m Vladimir Putin addressed Russia on
television calling the acts treasonous
and by that night 8 PM pagosian as far
as we currently understood understand a
halted the march on Moscow the reports
are that the coup attempt was foiled by
the Bella Russian president lukashenko
brokering a deal between Putin and
progosian allowing pagosian to escape to
Belarus in exchange for uh some kind of
Safe Haven presumably pagosians failed
coup attempt also has shown shifting
public opinion about him and the Wagner
group and quite frankly the f ethical
dilemmas of supporting or opposing coups
based on who it is that is doing them
this is a critical aspect to the story
pagosian's coup attempt
had mixed reactions among both Russians
and the International Community when
news broke of this and in fact I have
some Ukrainian friends who with tears in
their eyes wrote out wrote to me and I
could tell even though they were texting
that they had tears in their eyes they
were happy about this they welcomed it
as a challenge to Vladimir Putin's of
course authoritarian rule
uh and the idea that maybe there could
be Democratic change in Russia others
condemned the coup attempt saying it's
Reckless it's a violent act that
threatens Russia's stability it
threatens Russian Security even if the
coup were to succeed it's it does not
set Russia and the Russian people up for
really dramatically improved
circumstances there are those who say
Aku is never Justified regardless of the
regime that they are targeting because
who's undermine the rule of law they
undermine the will of the people others
say well sometimes the rule of law and
the will of the people has been
undermined by the strong man who is in
power already and the coup might be the
only way to actually get back on track
these are the various opinions that have
come forward one position
is that it's okay to support coups if
they are against
undemocratically elected leaders can it
be said that Putin was elected
democratically well he says he was
there's this ostensible democracy but
was it Putin won his fourth presidential
term with 77 of the vote in an election
that was widely criticized by domestic
and international observers for to put
it lightly
irregularities and violations so is
Putin actually democratically elected
Putin's main opponents were either
barred from running or jailed or even
worse Putin's critics were excluded from
the vote on constitutional reforms which
allowed Putin to reset term limits and
run for two more six-year terms that's
not democracy but does that mean we
support a coup attempt and then of
course the the other part of this is
that pragosian himself
initially seen by some favorably as
someone doing a good thing worthy of uh
the international left's support and
that very quickly came apart once more
was learned about pregosian and Wagner
group's activities in different theaters
around the world so that is where things
stand right now as far as we know there
is not total transparency about news
regarding exactly what is going on but
the broader and more forward-looking
question to which I just don't think we
have an answer if you Google what comes
next in Russia what happens next to
Putin you will find several dozen op-eds
from the last 24 to 48 hours no two
agree about what is coming next and in
particular for Vladimir Putin the most
optimistic sort of Blended scenario that
I've seen
put forth
is that now with the threat of the coup
but the coup having failed Vladimir
Putin May realize his days are numbered
and will engineer some kind of
face-saving exit from power to avoid
being deposed or whatever I just don't
know that that's really the most likely
scenario here so that's the latest we
have out of Russia as of this moment
we're going to continue following it
we'll probably have more for you
tomorrow or the next day today I want to
talk to you about a topic that has
become very controversial in the last
few days in the United States should
doctors and scientists debate
anti-vaxxers this is a question that's
been raised by many people in general in
the wake of the covid-19 pandemic but in
addition to that more recently we have
seen an argument take place
significantly happening on social media
between people like Joe Rogan and Elon
Musk and folks like Dr Peter Hotes who
um is a doctor and works on vaccines on
the one hand there's the argument that
doctors and scientists should not engage
in debates with anti-vaxxers because
when a doctor or a scientist debates an
anti-vaxxer they legitimize and lend
their credibility to an anti-vaxxer for
a position that doesn't actually deserve
legitimacy and credibility this is the
position of Dr Peter Hotes he's a doctor
a vaccine expert professor at the Baylor
College of Medicine and he has
frequently been targeted by anti-vaxx
harassment campaigns and even threats
Hotes says debating anti-vaxxers is a
losing proposition they're not
interested in facts or evidence they
want to spread fear and doubt and when
you engage with them in a supposed
debate you play into their hands you
give them a platform to reach more
people with their dangerous lies and
that it shouldn't be done Dr Peter Holtz
has also says that debating anti-vaxxers
from a practical standpoint is a waste
of time and a waste of resources because
there's real work that can be done
educating the public explaining the
benefits of vaccination and he says
instead of debating anti-vaxxers what
doctors and scientists should do is just
focus on communicating with people who
are hesitant about vaccines they're
unsure about vaccines they don't have
all of the information address their
concerns with empathy and respect and
that that's a much better use of time
and resources than debating anti-vaxxers
okay that's one side on the other hand
there are those who say doctors and
scientists should debate anti-vaxxers
now some of the people saying that are
the anti-vaxxers but even people who
accept the science and understand the
science of vaccines will sometimes say
no the doctors and the scientists should
debate the anti-vaxxers because when
they do that they can assuming the
doctors and scientists are correct they
will expose the flaws and the errors of
the anti-vaxxers they will potentially
persuade followers of the anti-vaxxers
to change their minds and to come to the
side of science and reason and I've
heard heard Joe Rogan make this argument
he's a popular podcast host and comedian
he's been accused by some of spreading
anti-vax misinformation and he says
listen the anti-vaxx movement has
followers already there's no downside to
debating them doctors and scientists who
are confident in their arguments and
that the facts are on their side can
actually do some good when the doctors
and scientists ignore or avoid the
anti-vaxxers they miss an opportunity
to challenge them and to show why they
are wrong and Joe Rogan also says that
when you debate anti-vaxxers you're
respecting their freedom of speech and
expression you're not participating in
censoring or silencing them which only
makes them more defiant or rebellious if
nobody is going to talk to them it will
make them more defiant and rebellious so
instead of dismissing anti-vaxxers as
crazy or stupid try to understand where
they're coming from what motivates them
to reject vaccines and meet them head on
and convince them with the facts that
potentially will win out
where am I on this issue I actually
don't think there is a simple or
definitive answer about whether doctors
and scientists should debate
anti-vaxxers and I'll explain why and I
will say one other thing before I delve
more deeply into this in general when it
comes to debates the person who wins is
most often just like more charismatic or
a better Communicator it's not
necessarily the person who's factually
correct and I think that that's a really
important thing to understand unless
it's opinions right we're just like okay
these are just opinions about what movie
is good or what food is good different
scenario when we're talking about
factual stuff where there is a truth
about vaccines
we have to remember that in general with
debate the better Communicator the more
articulate or charismatic person often
wins and you might be a scientist with
all the facts on your side but you just
might not be good in a so-called debate
format and that is something that has to
be considered as well okay
if you were talking about debating
vaccines in front of an audience that's
mostly people already convinced about
vaccines or supportive of vaccines then
I don't think it's really worth the time
to debate anti-vaxxers because you're
basically preaching to the choir you've
got a you've got a pro-vaccine audience
you debate an anti-vaxxer you do great
you haven't convinced anyone that
scenario seems like a waste of time
instead I would try to encourage people
to spread the word and advocate for
vaccination if you've got an audience of
people who are mostly undecided or
conflicted about vaccines then it might
make sense to consider debating
anti-vaxxers and I do think in those
situations doctors and scientists could
reach a key group of people
who might benefit from hearing both
sides of the argument assuming you have
charismatic and articulate people from
from medicine and science doctors and
scientists could appeal to the audience
and show them why vaccines are safe and
effective in addition to this if the
format is a structured debate
clear rules and criteria it benefits
those with the facts on their side which
in this case is doctors and scientists
and doctors and scientists who might shy
away from these insane sort of like kill
stream type insane Bonkers debates where
people just shout over each other that
doesn't seem like a good idea if you
have a more formal structured format
with a good moderator that also benefits
the side with the facts on their hands
and you're able to refute anti-vaxxers
with facts and data I think that's good
chaotic and formal debate without rules
and standards I think it's not a good
scenario in which the debate
anti-vaxxers uh you'd have you you'd
have uh you'd be at a disadvantage in
that sort of a scenario and it's better
not to get dragged into that so the
answer to should doctors and scientists
debate anti-vaxxers depends on a lot of
things it depends on what is the format
how serious or structured is the debate
who's in the audience what's the point
and what else could those doctors and
scientists be doing with their time as
usual these issues are not black and
white but I want to hear from you let me
know in a comment let me know in an
email what do you think about this core
question should medicine and science
debate anti-vaxxers or does it lend them
The credibility
and legitimacy that they should not be
given we'll take a quick break and be
back with much more right after this
I often have a much longer list of
non-fiction books that I'd like to read
than I actually have the time for and
that's when summaries of books can be
really useful our sponsor short form is
the platform that goes Way Beyond what
other book summary platforms do because
short form provides a clear and concise
overview of the book that you can read
or listen to in one sitting but you also
get a ton of other crucial context about
how the book fits into the broader topic
like for example I went through the
short form guide for an American
sickness it's a book by Elizabeth
Rosenthal about the financial incentives
that plague the U.S health care System
many of which we've talked about short
form perfectly sums up the book's key
points but then it goes further it looks
at the background on how rosenthal's
perspective fits into the larger debate
on American Health Care and this just
gives you a more complete and balanced
understanding of the book and that's
what I love about short form short form
has every non-fiction genre imaginable
and they publish new book guides every
single week my audience can try short
form totally free and get 25 off a
subscription if you'd like at
shortform.com Pacman the link is down
below
let's not forget that we're dealing with
Independent Community media here and we
are primarily supported by folks like
you people who watch some clips on
YouTube or listen to the audio podcast
or whatever the case may be we do the
show day in and day out for everybody we
give it away for free all of the content
other than the bonus show of course but
we do this subsidized by somewhere
around
0.7 percent of the audience that
supports us directly through mechanisms
like memberships at joinpakman.com you
uh that group 0.7 percent which maybe we
could go to grow to one percent or one
and a half percent someday these are the
folks making the show possible for
everybody at no cost and so I encourage
you to sign up at joinpakman.com and
among other great member benefits you do
get access to the Daily bonus show an
incredible award-winning extra show on
which today I will be telling a number
of of very interesting stories from my
trip last week's joinpakman.com is the
place to sign up you can use the coupon
code indicted again
let's talk about one of the most
controversial candidates in the 2024
primary field the Democratic
presidential primary I'm talking about
Robert F Kennedy Jr now as a reminder
Bobby Kennedy Jr is the son of Robert F
Kennedy Robert F Kennedy was
assassinated while running for president
an extraordinarily gifted politician was
Robert F Kennedy Bobby Kennedy Jr is
also the nephew of former president John
F Kennedy who is of course also
assassinated while serving as president
so Bobby Kennedy comes from this
political Dynasty that has impacted
American political history for a very
long time Environmental Lawyer activist
Who has fought for clean water and
renewable energy and climate justice has
a long record of advocacy for really
important issues poverty civil rights
Health Care democracy things that he
truly inherited from his late Father
Robert Kennedy and he's a super
interesting candidate and a nice guy who
I've met I had dinner with we have many
friends in common and also
he has become a very powerful
anti-vaccine voice he says he's not
against vaccines but simply for tested
and safe vaccines but when we actually
look at the disinformation that he has
spread not only about vaccines but also
talking about hydroxychloroquine as if
it's proven to work for Cove I mean
there's a long list of concerning stuff
from Bobby Kennedy Jr he's made
concerning comments about Russia and
Ukraine taking the some sort of strange
softly pro-putin perspectives he has
talked about
um uh he's actually talked about gay
frog said I'm talking about Bobby
Kennedy Jr here not Alex Jones
um and he also I mean just like as
another example he's made wild
unsubstantiated claims about China he
recently said on Newsmax of all places
that China is developing a racist bio
weapon that targets People based on
ethnicity listen to this well what what
I worry about is is a wmd like a virus I
think gain of function something do you
worry about that because I see that as
sort of the next the next big fight
because you know those viruses don't see
any borders and uh and they're
relatively cheap to do this gain of
function I mean it's just so that's what
I worry about more than the big Hardware
yeah you're exactly right and we know
that the Chinese
are developing ethnic bio weapons bio
weapons that are designed to attack
people of certain racial types and the
and we're doing the same thing we okay
so does he provide any evidence that
that's happening he does not
is there any evidence that I was able to
find no I was able to find some
conjecture about this from last month
also without evidence but I was not able
to find any evidence that that's going
on is it possible that you could make a
racist bio weapon it might be possible
so so like an ethnic bio weapon
hypothetically which targets people of
specific ethnicities or races or
genotypes
could conceivably be created but experts
and officials say it's it's not totally
clear that you could do it uh you might
be able to genetically engineer some
pathogen to Target DNA markers that are
specific to some racial or ethnic group
maybe like maybe it could be done
another possibility would be like a gene
therapy that creates a virus to Target
particular DNA sequences but there are
many forget about the ethical challenges
let's assume the ethics go out the
window there are some insane technical
challenges to do this and one of them is
the one that often comes up in debates
about IQ there is such genetic diversity
within ethnic groups that such a
technology
would be extremely difficult to actually
do what I'm not saying it's impossible
but right now extreme hurdles and no
evidence that it's being done but Bobby
Kennedy says oh this thing is happening
another example Bobby Kennedy Jr is
hosting a so-called Health policy
Roundtable
featuring unhinged conspiracy theorists
Sherry Tenpenny Sherry Tenpenny is this
um uh
person I don't want to get into the
whole osteopathy thing again she she's a
a an individual who happens to be an
osteopath who has
um made all sorts of insane claims about
everyone you know is soon going to be
dead from the covid vaccine and uh all
of these other things so how do we what
do we make of Bobby Kennedy Jr is he a
viable Challenger to Joe Biden should we
support or oppose him for me the the
situation is pretty clear Bobby Kennedy
Jr is articulate articulate and smart
he delivers really powerful speeches
even with the struggles of his voice
with the dysphonia he still
delivers very powerful speeches he
appeals to emotion and reason in a way
that clearly resonates with people he
has a personal story and a family Legacy
that can be inspirational to voters he's
right on many issues when you look at
health care and green New Deal
minimum wage Criminal Justice Reform
voting rights expansion ending Wars
Bobby Kennedy Jr is right on many issues
on the other side
he is dangerously unhinged in some areas
the promotion of unproven conspiracy
theories the pseudoscience this stuff
really undermines some of the core
structures that go towards public health
and National Security
um he seems disconnected with reality
quite frankly on some of those issues he
will often attack fellow Democrats who
happen to disagree with him on some of
these issues he's supported by a Super
PAC tied to Maga he seems to be gaining
support from folks on the right who see
him merely as a Chaos Agent potentially
to derail Joe Biden and put a hardcore
right winger in the Oval Office so
on the one hand there is much to like
about Bobby Kennedy Jr
in some sense I would love to support
the guy
um but based on his current positions I
don't think that that's something that I
can do I also don't think he can win the
nomination nor the general election uh
with the views that he has he may be
able to he may be able to damage Joe
Biden
um but I don't believe that he has a
path to the Democratic nomination nor am
I convinced at this point that he would
have a path to the presidency if he
somehow got on the ballot let me know
your thoughts I am not just laughing him
off I'm actually giving you a more
nuanced perspective than some are
willing to give about Bobby Kennedy Jr
but at this point it doesn't seem like
in its totality it's something that I
can support let's take a look at the
latest uh between Chris Christie and the
failed twice indicted twice impeached
former president Donald Trump as you may
remember Donald Trump attacked Chris
Christie for his weight listen Chris
Christie is obese there's no question
about it but as I said at the time uh
several weeks ago Donald Trump is also
obese and one of the real signs of
occult leader as is Donald Trump is that
a cult leader can criticize others for
things that they themselves could be
criticized for and their followers don't
care care about the double standard they
don't care about the person in a glass
house throwing stones or the pot calling
the kettle black or whatever phrase you
want to use here is Chris Christie asked
on Fox about the fact that Trump goes
after him for his weight and Chris
Christie points out Trump's fat Trump's
also fat once Trump started hitting back
at you on a number of fronts he took aim
at your weight what was your reaction to
that oh well like he Summit on us I mean
please uh you know look Howie there are
tens of millions of Americans out in
your audience watching right now who
like me have struggled with their weight
true I continue to struggle I continue
to try to do better
um and so do they and what's that got to
do with my competence for office I ran
the governorship of New Jersey for eight
years I think in a very energetic
successful way responding to Hurricane
Sandy working 20 hours a day for weeks I
don't know what his point is you know
what it is it's like a child it's a
bully on the schoolyard who teases you
and makes fun of you but here's my
message to him I don't care what he says
about me and I don't care what he thinks
about me and he should take a look in
the mirror every once in a while maybe
he dropped the weight thing off of his
list of criticisms yeah so Chris
Christie is completely correct of course
you might remember that at one point
Donald Trump published this totally
corrosive uh truth to truth Central
where Trump said quote how many times
did Chris Christie use the word small
does he have a psychological problem
with size actually his speech was small
and not very good okay he goes on he
also posted this photoshopped meme
from Chris Christie's Oak campaign
opener Town Hall where it looks like
Christy is at a buffet of some kind
holding like a massive plate of food and
yeah there's a million other examples of
this uh Trump's obese okay remember that
Trump claimed with the help of Dr Ronnie
Jackson to weigh 239 and be six foot
three inches tall we know that Trump is
not six feet three inches tall uh when
you see him standing next to a Tom Brady
for example or you see him standing next
to Barack Obama Obama you realize that
Trump is very much not 6'3 just being
shorter than six three alone would make
him obese also nobody believes he weighs
239 somewhere in the 260 270 range seems
to make a lot more sense so Trump is
obese but the point here is
this is what cult leaders get away with
the cult followers allow you to
criticize others for things that are
also characteristics about you
Chris Christie is right to point out to
the Fox News audience Trump is also fat
now sure Chris Christie is more visibly
obese than Trump there's no doubt about
it but the point I think would be best
made here is to turn this into a losing
argument instead of saying anything else
say okay yeah I'm overweight so is Trump
so are tens of millions of Americans is
this really the issue that we have
facing us now we'll talk about how Chris
Christie's polling has improved and it
has improved but is it really going
anywhere viable we don't really know the
answer to that
um we'll see what the reaction is to
this latest commentary from Chris
Christie but Chris Christie is Right
Trump's obese
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
it's hard to believe my friends but
Donald Trump glitching badly at a recent
speech in Washington D.C suggesting more
crimes if he were to be elected
president of the United States a second
time this was again at some kind of
religious event in Washington DC over
the weekend here Donald Trump says if he
becomes president he will deny entry to
the United States to Communists and
marxists is this potentially legal I'll
tell you in a moment listen to what the
failed former president twice indicted
twice impeached had to say to a
disgusting sycophant crowd made them
competitive today I'm announcing a new
plan to protect the Integrity of our
immigration system federal law prohibits
the entry of Communists and
totalitarians into the United States
[Applause]
ones that are already here that grew up
I think we have to pass a new law for
them
using federal law in section
212 F of the immigration and nationality
act I will order my government to deny
entry to all Communists and all marxists
wow
quite an idea
those who come to and join our country
must love our country we want them to
love our country we don't want them when
they want to destroy our country welcome
to America we want to destroy your
country thank you very much so we're
going to keep foreign Christian hating
Communists marxists and socialists out
of America all right so you get the idea
keep communist marxists and socialists
out of the United States also equating
being a socialist to hating America
there's many socialists who like America
in the same way that there's many people
who think gun laws should be more
permissive who like America just because
you want something to be different
doesn't mean you hate America but what
Trump is proposing is almost certainly
against the law and impossible from a
practical perspective it's against the
law because Trump's idea
would violate the First Amendment of the
United States Constitution it protects
freedom of speech religion press
assembly and petition communism and
Marxism are political ideologies that
people have the right to express and
they have the right to believe in them
as long as they are not advocating for
violence or an overthrow of the
government they are allowed to believe
those things it is also against the law
because it would violate the equal
protection Clause of the 14th Amendment
which prohibits discrimination based on
race ethnicity national origin or other
arbitrary criteria communism and Marxism
and socialism are not inherent traits of
any ethnic or racial group they are
movements and they are quite complex
movements by the way which have
followers from different backgrounds in
different countries it's impossible from
a practical perspective to do this
because there's no clear or objective
way to define who is a communist or a
Marxist there are many different
branches in schools and interpretations
of Communism and Marxism some are
contradictory some are incompatible with
each other and there are also many
people who just like one aspect of
Communism or Marxism like uh if for
example are you a communist if you want
to nationalize the airlines I don't know
you you can't come to the U.S on that
basis are you a Marxist if you believe
in the labor theory of value
doesn't make any sense and that's why
it's impossible from a practical
perspective how can you reliably screen
or monitor people's political beliefs at
the border and do you think for a second
that those who say governments
incompetent everybody's incompetent they
now want to deputize immigrations and
Customs Enforcement to quiz individuals
about the political beliefs and
determine if they are communistic
socialistic or Marxist it's insane and
ridiculous and almost certainly against
the law which makes it a perfect
proposal for Donald Trump a couple other
clips from this ridiculous speech Trump
also said that on day one of his
presidency he will again try to ban
trans people from the military
and on day one I will reinstate the
Trump ban on transgenders in the
military wow
because our Warriors should be focused
on crushing American enemies on being
strong on having the image of being
strong they have to be powerful they
have to be strong especially when you
see what's happening in the world today
yeah so first of all as usual the
biggest Applause line during Trump's
entire speech when what it was when he
said he would ban trans people from the
military think of how crazy that is
though men are allowed in the military
okay nobody denies that women are
allowed in the military
I don't think anyone denies that even
though there are people on the right who
don't like that so why would you ban
trans people if men and women are
allowed in the military why on Earth
would you ban trans people and of course
we we have a number of studies about
this and it makes no sense to ban trans
people from the military Trump did the
entire thing about yes I'm a victim but
really this is about you saying he is
being invited for them whatever that
means every time the radical left
Democrats marxists Communists and
fascists indict me I consider it a great
Badge of Courage
right
okay
[Applause]
I'm being indicted for you and I believe
the you is more than 200 million people
that love our country they're out there
um as as usual we don't know exactly
what these numbers mean 200 million
people Trump has said he has hundreds of
millions of supporters in the country uh
he doesn't certainly even if you assume
that he has twice as many supporters as
the number that voted for him that still
puts it at 150 million or or under and I
think we all know that the number is
actually quite smaller much smaller than
that but this is part of the grift the
way he grifts money on indictments which
he's doing will maybe we'll look at some
fundraising emails he sent maybe we
won't we probably won't actually I'll
just tell you he's sending out grifty
fundraising emails and part of the
reason that he's doing it is he has come
up with this storyline of they're really
going after you when they go after me
it's part of the victimhood complex and
then lastly here Trump again misstating
the law about classified documents
claiming he just there's no crime and he
could do whatever he wanted with the
documents
well it is true
I mean it is true
in other words whatever documents the
president decides to take with him he
has the absolute right to take them
really he has the absolute right to keep
them or he can give them back to Nara if
he wants he talks to them like we were
doing and he can do that if he wants
that's the law and it couldn't be more
clear okay so as Democratic Congressman
Daniel Goldman explained on Twitter this
is an argument that should be blocked
from even being made during Donald
Trump's trial because it is a false
representation of the law one of the
things you're not allowed to do in a
defense is to misstate what the law is
the judge will instruct the jury as to
what the law is and uh the special
counsel prosecutors will likely move to
preclude Trump from making this argument
in court because it is simply not what
the law says this is a TV argument that
Trump is making this is a PR argument
this is a grift argument that Trump is
making it is not actually what the law
says so another weekend
another completely unhinged and
dangerous speech from the failed former
president let's now look at what's
happening with polling in the 2024
Republican primary I come to you today
to tell you
that Chris Christie's polling is now up
150 percent since he announced he was
running for president
however this puts him at two and a half
so listen percentage-wise things are
going in the right direction for Chris
Christie the the clearly the most sane
and rational person running in the 2024
Republican primary but is it going to be
enough I don't know so let's take a look
at some data Chris Christie announced
that he was running uh on June 6th but
we learned that he was running on May
31st June 1st so we're going to look at
how polling has changed for the
Republican candidates the top ones
between June 1st and today Trump for
example was at 53 when Christie
announced uh and he is now at 52. so
Trump is down two percent since
Christie's announcement DeSantis is
totally flat absolutely flat totally not
woke at all DeSantis was at 22 and he's
still at 22. so he has not seen any
polling change Mike Pence was at four
but is now at six pence has gained 50
percent Nikki Haley Unchained changed
four and four Tim Scott was at two
percent now polling four percent he has
gained 100 support doubling it and then
there is Chris Christie
who was polling one percent
announced his candidacy and is now
polling 2.5 percent that is a gain of
150 percent
now am I being serious well I'm being
serious but I'm also going to be honest
with you about small numbers small
numbers in general can be inaccurate or
meaningless in exactly these sorts of
situations when you're looking at
changes because such small numbers can
be affected by rounding they can be
affected by data truncation they can be
affected by inflation context sample
size so for example if someone goes to
from one to two percent in polling it's
technically an increase of a hundred
percent you've gone from one to two it's
mostly meaningless because these numbers
are so small that they really may not
reflect the preferences of the
population and these small changes can
easily be influenced by random error
measurement uncertainty sampling bias
Etc so you do get rid of a little bit of
this by using averages of polls which we
are doing
is Chris Christie gaining I believe
Chris Christie is gaining but to say
that he has really gained 150 support
since his announcement
maybe is a bit further than we can go
what we are starting to get a picture of
and this is really important is that it
may not be so simple
to significantly shift massive amounts
of support in the Republican primary
Trump's now been indicted twice DeSantis
went from a potential candidate to a
real candidate Trump's basically flat
DeSantis is basically flat nobody else
is polling any more than six percent
so if there's any real takeaway right
now forget about oh they were at one now
they're at three or whatever the case
may be the big takeaway for me is that
it is proving difficult to see
significant moves in Republican voters
the next Milestone of course becomes
well number one does Trump get indicted
between July and September in Georgia
and number two in late August the first
Republican primary debate will take
place on Fox News Brett Bayer will be
hosting it does Trump show up to that
debate and does the debate performance
actually shift the numbers in any
serious way we have plenty of time to
think about that this is where the
polling is today we're going to take the
quickest break make sure you're
subscribed on YouTube at youtube.com the
davidpackman show and the show will
simply continue in a moment
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show last week
our a great guest host who filled in for
me did a great job covering the plea
agreement that Hunter Biden has reached
with the justice department I don't
really have much to add other than my
position has always been if there's
evidence that Hunter Biden did anything
wrong investigate them if it points to
charges charge them and then either try
him or strike a plea deal do don't do
anything special for the guy because he
is the son of President Joe Biden okay
so that happened and uh now the right is
starting to cook up all sorts of
additional conspiracy theories of course
many on the right are saying well he was
able he was allowed to get a plea deal
that avoids prison time because he's the
son of Joe Biden there's no evidence of
that the evidence is that
um uh his his plea deal was very much in
line with what many would see if they
are represented by competent counsel in
such a situation so that line isn't
going very well for the right so the new
one is this is just so so amazing over
the weekend as uh attention went to this
failed coup attempt in Russia which we
talked about at the top of the show over
on Fox News Maria Bartiromo yesterday
came up with the conspiracy theory
that the entire coup attempt
might have been fabricated to take
attention away from Hunter Biden if you
can believe that now you might say David
that doesn't make any sense there's no
evidence for that of course of course
but we're operating or they are
operating in a different world listen to
this
oh
we have a glitched clip I'm glitching
almost as badly As Trump hold on here we
go so does it break through and become a
real problem the White House wanted to
give the media something else to cover
and this is the mo this is exactly the
way they do things in fact the White
House wanted to give the media something
else to cover okay Friday I said wow
what a blockbuster what's that message
I'm sure there will be an enormous story
over the weekend that the White House is
going to be pushing to take this story
off of the front page and sure enough
we've got the state department drumming
up all the drama that took place over
the weekend in Russia so I don't know if
it's going to break through the
mainstream media has an excuse again not
to cover it they're covering everything
about Russia and the Wagner group yeah
it's true as if it really matters to the
U.S right now yeah by the way you
mentioned
um
as if it matters to the U.S whether the
authoritarian leader of one of the three
Global superpowers of which the U.S is
one as if it matters whether they are
deposed in a coup ah it doesn't really
matter and it's distracting from the
hunter Biden story what on Earth is
wrong with these people and it's
important to remember that according to
them
the first Trump arrest was meant to
distract from something and now I
actually don't remember I don't remember
if it was inflation does anybody in the
audience remember what the first Trump
arrest was meant to distract from was it
something about Biden
Biden tripping or something like that
anyway the first Trump arrest was meant
to be a distraction uh from that the
second Trump arrest was meant to be a
distraction from the explosive claims of
a whistleblower about Joe Biden a
whistleblower they can't find uh whose
recordings may not exist look that was
that was the second the reason for the
second Trump arrest and then now the
entire Russian coup attempt is to
distract from Hunter Biden uh a
potential coup that would destabilize an
adversarial superpower that also happens
to have gobs of nuclear weapons not
really a story what matters much more is
Hunter Biden using drugs and his
WhatsApp text messages or something like
that
um once again the details Hunter Biden
has pleaded guilty or will plead guilty
to two tax misdemeanors and he struck a
deal to also resolve a gun charge
according to the justice department he
failed to pay at least 100K in taxes in
2017 and 2018 by their deadlines he has
since fully repaid those taxes as well
as the fines and he unlawfully possessed
a gun for 11 days in 2018 he knew he
wasn't supposed to have a gun and uh
that that's what happened so he has
struck a deal and the good news is that
now that we see that Hunter Biden did
have to face consequences we can all
rest easy knowing that it's not only
Trump who is going to have to uh be
adjudicated for the things he allegedly
did right are we ready to say that the
two-tier justice system of Republicans
and Democrats isn't actually a thing no
we're not because the new argument is
Hunter got a sweetheart deal
because he's a Democrat and the son of
Joe Biden this is a reminder I told you
guys this a year ago
if they ever do go after Hunter Biden
the right isn't going to let up they
will simply say he wasn't charged
seriously enough
or he was given a light sentence or a
slap on the wrist or whatever because of
Joe Biden and that is exactly what they
are now saying radical and repugnant
Republican congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
Greene is now claiming that her
television turns itself on to spy on her
no she's not crazy no she's not taking
any medications as she proudly has
announced although maybe she should be
as The Daily Beast reports green posted
a bizarre thread Sunday morning in which
she insinuated she's being spied on Via
her television uh
yeah uh her first tweet says last night
in my DC residence the television turned
on by itself and the screen showed
someone's laptop trying to connect to
the TV just for the record I'm very
happy I'm also very healthy and eat well
and exercise a lot I don't smoke and
never have I don't take any medications
I'm not vaccinated so I'm not concerned
about blood clots heart conditions
Strokes or anything else nor do I have
anything to hide I just love my country
and the people and know how much they've
been screwed over by the corrupt people
in our government and I'm not willing to
be quiet about it or willing to go along
with it now it is actually funny to see
how the supposed we don't care about our
feelings we only care about our facts
crowd immediately accepted this and said
yes the most likely scenario is indeed
that someone probably leftists or antifa
are trying to spy on green through her
television that's almost certainly what
is going on
of course at some point it might be nice
to apply a sort of colloquial version of
Occam's razor is there a simpler
explanation here and of course there
almost certainly is did this not really
happen and is she lying that's a
possibility more likely than the one she
is outlining did she sit on the remote
that is a possibility is it a smart TV
with some kind of learning function that
maybe has figured out a schedule where
it believes Marjorie Taylor green wants
to be watching TV sure is it her
boyfriend Brian Glenn the guy from right
side broadcasting who hooked up his
laptop to the TV and uh it turned on and
went right to the last input that was
selected like any single one of these
explanations would make more sense but
then but then Marjorie Taylor green
posts an article from CBS News your
smart TV might be spying on you
now of course
what that warning means by spying is
that without your consent it's
conceivable that the microphone function
on the TV might be listening to words or
phrases that would then be used to
Target advertising towards you or that a
camera could be gathering data about
when you're sitting in front of the TV
versus when that's that's the type of
spying we're talking about we're not
talking about leftists remotely turning
on marjorie's TV
in order to be able to listen I guess to
whatever the hell it is she's talking
about politically okay so Marjorie
Taylor green insisting she's not on any
medications but maybe she should be that
would be something to look at we have a
voicemail number that number is
2192 David P
here is a caller
who is worried about me and I always
appreciate concern from people in the
audience
hey David it's James I was watching some
of your earlier videos from uh I guess
not not super earlier but these from a
couple years ago one particular stands
out
um I believe it was called caller needs
help with Jewish person and you seem
like you were in a much better place
you're in much higher spirits of the
time you seemed more joyful uh but then
you you have recently I was wondering
are you all right did something happen
you seem kind of down in the dumps
recently well I appreciate the concern
um nothing in particular has happened
um certainly the State of Affairs in the
United States is quite sad that is true
so I think it would be logical as
someone who's steeped in how things are
going
uh to be sort of concerned but at the
same time the video that the caller is
referring to I believe happened while
Trump was President which was certainly
a dark time in American history so no I
appreciate the concern nothing in
particular is wrong I mean listen let's
be honest chasing around a baby is
exhausting so if anything could be
blamed for tiredness or whatever
um certainly it would be it would be
that but no everything is fine thanks
for asking on the bonus show today folks
we have a fantastic bonus show today I
just got back from a wedding in
California I am going to talk about uh
elements that took place on the flight
some unfortunate confrontations that
took place not good I'm going to talk
about running into some really nice
folks who watch the show while I was in
the Bay area of California met some
great people just by chance there was no
event or anything just ran into some
people I am going to talk about what
else am I going to talk about
I I have stories I have stories from
California we are also going to talk
about an investigation into the cause of
the implosion of that Titanic
submersible we're going to discuss that
and also Japan has a plan to boost birth
rates we've talked about the plan before
is it a viable plan we're starting to
gather data
one city
has reason to hope that this is a good
plan for Japan to raise birth rates
where birth rates are getting
dangerously low from a political
standpoint all of those stories and more
will be in none other than today's bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money yeah everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad
and of course after being back for one
day I will be off for the next three
weeks no I'm kidding I'm we're back
we're back for a while uh before before
the next break it's not even really a
break anymore you know by the way let's
just talk a little bit about the guest
hosts every time we have guest hosts I
get emails all right I'm going to tell
everybody right now
I know that not everybody likes the
guest hosts I know it because every
guest host we have no matter what we get
emails from people saying I couldn't
bear to watch it some people liked Luke
but they didn't like Pat some people
like Pat but they didn't like Luke some
people didn't like either some people
said both were fine but it wasn't that
good so I'm just gonna put it out there
we used to have no shows when I would be
away it wasn't really
robust one of the things I've wanted to
do is have a more robust show that can
continue when I'm gone we now have
multiple people who can do the producer
role we have a rotating cast of guest
hosts I understand and I'm flattered
that when I'm gone
some people say David I'd rather have
you here and that makes sense because
you're watching this show or listening
to this show rather than some other show
so I get that and I love that and I'm
flattered by it but you don't have to
email me that you don't like the guest
hosts or all of the guest hosts because
I know that not everybody likes them
viewership goes down when we have a
guest host but my opinion is and people
in the audience seem to agree it's
better to have a guest host rather than
no show
or a repeat show because if it's part of
your routine to listen to a podcast on
the way to work on the way to the gym
whatever and you don't necessarily want
to find something else we have something
there and I think viewership is usually
down about 30 percent when we have guest
hosts which isn't really that bad I have
to tell you all right so
you you you can always email for any
reason but if you're just emailing in to
say hey I didn't like the guest host we
know we see that in the data and we're
going to continue working to have a
great rotating slate of hosts that will
hold down the fort until I get back all
right more about my trip on the bonus
show we'll be back tomorrow we have a
very strong week of programming
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors for all of the
books I don't have time for I use short
form which condenses thousands of
non-fiction books down into an excellent
summary that I can read or listen to all
at once short form goes chapter by
chapter providing deeper analysis than
other summary platforms for a more
comprehensive understanding of any topic
try it free and get 25 off using my link
below